all right wrapping up this monday
edition of pftpm and i'm getting back to
work at profootballtalk.com because the
news keeps flowing into the night
rob andrews 77 shereen has this question
for us on twitter where's trent williams
going to or will he stay in the bay i
know the 49ers very much would like to
keep him i've seen indications they're
willing to pay as much as 20 million per
year laramie tunzel set the high bar for
new money at 22 million per year on the
long term deal he did last year the
bears reportedly have interest in trent
williams i think multiple teams will be
interested in trent williams even though
he's 32 he's the guy who walks right
through the door as you're starting left
tackle and stabilizes your offensive
line i thought the chiefs may be
interested now that they paid you toony
they probably don't have the money to do
it the vikings were interested last year
they've cut riley reef although the
vikings need the cap space to make that
happen this is a guy who can go anywhere
the colts with anthony castanzo retired
although the colts resist making those
big deals out of the gates this is a guy
that that maybe you do what you have to
do because you know what he can do for
you if you get him on your team
yeah john lynch has done a great job so
far re-signing those free agents we
didn't talk about d4 d ford is going to
stay with the 49ers and we talked about
jason verrette and some of the other
moves that the 49ers have made i think
this is a guy that they're they've
prioritized him to keep him sort of like
eric armstead last year they let him hit
the market to see what was out there for
him he came back into the fold i think
tripp williams stays with the 49ers
ultimately mike
yeah we'll see if they can work that out
and absolutely the 49ers did what they
had to do to keep kyle yuschik their
full back there are certain players that
you just absolutely need on that team in
order for that team to be as good as it
can be and even though williams was new
to the team last year he took over for
joe staley i saw rumblings recently and
i think staley was joking around about
possibly coming out of retirement if the
49ers lose trent williams maybe they'll
maybe they'll make sure that that was
just a joke from joe staley 24 colada as
the buccaneers would you cut cameron
breit to bring back gronk i don't think
no it's mutually exclusive you keep both
guys right you need two oj howard's
gonna be gone he had the achilles tear
and he's a free agent you you need you
need two guys yeah they like having two
tight ends i think you find a way to
keep both of them as you can shireen
yeah and i really like brayton i know
the bucks really like breaks so no
they're going to keep great and hope
they can bring gronk back but even if
gronk doesn't come back camera breaks on
that team mike
very affordable at 6.25 million dollars
in salary this year as well a red zone
out do you see any free agents deciding
to opt out for you rather than take a
below market deal sharing that's
something you've been talking about the
possibility that once we get to the
point where the money's not there the
offers aren't where some of these
veterans want them to be they may just
say see you later i'm taking this year
off i'm opting out for financial reasons
and i'll jump back in when the salary
cap goes up in 2022.
yeah i think that could happen and i
think a lot of what we see too mike is
guys just going no i'm not going to sign
now i'm going to wait for an injury to
happen at some point and and it does and
maybe they skipped training camp and
come back that first week of the season
but i do think we're going to see some
of that how much of it i don't know but
the money is not going to be there for a
lot of these mid-level range guys that
we've talked a lot about mike
we always knew there were going to be
plenty of guys who get signed right out
of the gates it's how long until it
slows to a trickle and once the money
dries up
what's going to be there for guys who
thought they were getting more that's
the key and that's something that's
going to be determined as time passes
and the dust settles last one from crown
prince k with a crown with a k or k with
a crown do you think the giants will
part ways with jabril peppers
i don't think so mike i think they'll
end up keeping him i know he has a a
high cap number for this year but i
think they keep him i think they would
have already made that move if they were
going to make it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports